hello neil and buzz
this certainly has to be the most
historic telephone call
ever made
for every american this has to be the
proudest day of our lives
[Music]
if you go back to the dawn of the space
age they were very much the right stuff
fighter pilot jocks
the first generation were recruited out
of the in the u.s air force
the profile of someone who would go into
space you know has a certain look and
feel a certain prototype to it
i mean really up until now if you had a
disability you know you would have
naturally assumed that
space flight was not an option for you
we believe it's time to assess the
feasibility of sending astronauts with
physical disabilities into space
[Music]
you know without the force of gravity
and in a totally different environment
we have an opportunity to create a new
norm and an environment where really we
can accommodate any type of body and
there is no disabled or able-bodied body
rather everyone's the same
you look back in history
to seeing the difference
that putting women in space made and
putting people of colour in space made
the same i'm sure will be true when we
open those doors and to people with with
disabilities
it's just the start i think and i don't
know where it's going to lead
[Music]
in 1959 the first u.s astronauts were
selected
all seven men were military personnel
but before these astronauts came the
gallaudet 11.
the gallaudet 11 were a real important
group and i don't know if you can see
this
picture or not
the gallaudet project was really
initiated by ashton grabiel who was one
of the pioneers in
space flight
he tested all of the early astronauts he
was especially interested in human
responses to acceleration
and to unusual forces
[Music]
dr grabiel who was working with nasa
chose 11 volunteers who shared a very
specific characteristic
they were all deaf
spinal meningitis had disrupted their
inner ear vestibular system also known
as the labyrinth which is devoted
exclusively to the detection of
acceleration
for a decade they underwent various
experiments that included living 12 days
in a 20-foot rotation room and sailing
in extremely rough waters during a storm
in the north atlantic
in every single provocative situation in
which he tested the labyrinthine lost
subjects there were no symptoms of
motion sickness
the funny part of it is throughout it
most of the crew
and all of the people coordinating the
labyrinthine law subjects
were vomiting their hearts out as people
in the trade say they were barfing
and
the labyrinthine lost subjects were just
sitting playing cards
having a ball
nasa was then better able to understand
how the body's sensory systems work and
the effects of prolonged weightlessness
and space motion sickness
i think there's a lot of reasons why
people with disabilities actually are
really well suited to be astronauts the
first thing that comes to mind is that
people with disabilities are used to
being very nimble
and to being very dynamic and responsive
to thinking quickly and problem solving
right
and so all those are characteristics
that would be highly desirable for an
astronaut right like having that quick
response time and being able to think
creatively about new solutions to
problems that might develop
while the gallaudet 11 made human
spaceflight possible they've been
forgotten from its history
and since then differently abled
individuals have largely been cut out of
the astronaut process
until now
earlier this year the european space
agency announced that it would not only
be hiring new astronauts for the first
time since 2008 but it would also be
running a feasibility project in the
hopes of training its first disabled
astronaut
this was something we've been talking
about in-house for the past two or three
years he used to call it project x the
head of the astronaut center
because we kind of asked ourselves the
question uh we've always had these basic
minimum medical standards but they've
always called for somebody that
able-bodied in the traditional sense but
the question was well why have we asked
ourselves whether we could fly somebody
with a physical disability
to the space station
and so alongside the call for the
mainstream core astronaut corps we've
introduced this feasibility study for a
para astronaut
like the gallaudet 11 program there are
very specific requirements for those
taking part in the esa's feasibility
project
in this first call they selected
different types of amputees at different
levels of lower limb involvement as well
as individuals of short stature
and honestly i think it was a really
smart move because these are clearly
like
very well-defined disabilities
but they are primarily musculoskeletal
in nature fairly uncomplicated from a
physiologic standpoint yet there's this
musculoskeletal feature that creates a
visible difference and therefore
categorizes them as disabled so to speak
um
and you know for that reason when you
think about all the complexities of
space flight of being an astronaut it's
definitely like a really good starting
point
the esa has committed an initial budget
of one million euros and will be working
with two or three selected applicants on
what technical adaptations existing
spacecrafts and stations may need
ignition
for example for the launch vehicle for
the crew capsule that gets them up to
the space station
we the europeans don't have our own
vehicle so that means we're going to
have to work with the u.s providers
there's boeing and the spacex who send
astronauts up to the space station so
we're going to have to work technically
with them they're going to have to also
train to be a regular astronaut because
what's important for us is this is not
kind of a joy ride we want them to be
able to participate in a meaningful
mission aboard the international space
station
to undertake maintenance tasks to run
scientific experiments and so on
you know in the disability community we
use this phrase called universal design
and i think what the para astronaut
program is pushing us to think about is
again designing our environments so that
they're more universal and suited for
everybody and every type of ability
level you know from day one without
having to retrofit it later down the
road so i think that thinking about
universal design as it relates to to
settlements in other planets or space in
general helps us to really reframe that
and to think about you know whether
you're an infant or someone who's 100
years old whether you're large or small
whether you have a visible disability or
not you know what what type of
environment can we envision that reduces
the barriers for everyone to the
greatest extent possible
some of the adaptive support systems
these individuals use on a daily basis
may no longer be needed in space
an environment that could level the
playing field for many who are
considered disabled on earth
when you look at the international space
station
everybody floats up there your use of
your feet
in space isn't really needed and in fact
astronauts come back with very soft
feet because they haven't been used
for all that time so um the adaptations
on the space station they will be
considered but i imagine them to be
not massively
challenging because of the environment
that you are in
once you're in zero-g environment the
legs are not tremendously useful of
course the astronauts spend a lot of
time doing physical exercise to maintain
their health so that when they come back
to earth they're in a good state because
if you don't do so you lose muscle mass
and you also lose bone mass
astronauts can lose as much as 10
percent of bone density during six
months in space
to offset the effect they exercise for
two hours a day at least six days a week
they do an hour of cardio perhaps
running on a treadmill and exercising on
a bicycle and they do an hour of what
what you and i might refer to as
weightlifting now in space you can't
lift weights nothing has a weight
because you don't feel gravity um but we
use um sort of hydraulic springs like
like resistance uh to tension those
those muscles and so on
maintaining bone and muscle mass will be
critical for para astronauts
but as humans venture further from earth
more room on rockets and space stations
is needed for fuel so space is at a
premium
[Music]
one innovation that could let exercise
take up less space and time is the high
frequency impulse for microgravity or
hi-fi m
hi-fi m promises to reduce the
astronauts current workouts to just six
minutes a day on one machine
it does this by enabling astronauts to
jump in zero gravity
[Music]
so to be able to jump is a fantastic way
to lower the skeletal system build up
muscle density and also cardiovascularly
it's ferocious on the body
through esa bed rest studies we've
proven that jumping will mitigate
bone density and muscle mass loss with
just
50 jumps a day that's four to six
minutes a day that's amazing the time
that's going to give astronauts back to
do experiments and more science in space
but you can't just jump because you've
got to make sure the load and vibration
does not go through the spacecraft so
hi-fi m is designed to absorb its own
load and vibration when an individual is
jumping
hi-fi m has been developed with both
astronauts and para astronauts in mind
former royal marine lee spencer has been
trialling the machine throughout its
prototype phase
my left leg was really badly damaged
when i lost
my right leg and that really means that
i can't actually sprint or jump but the
great thing that this does
is it allows you as an amputee to train
in a way that i've not been able to
train before and that's with explosive
muscle movements where you you can jump
again
we can actually control the load that's
going through his prosthetic and then
into his limb so we can develop
the bone density and muscle mass through
that limb through both limbs through his
pelvis through his spine but also
condition the point
where the stump of his leg meets the
prosthetic
and we can condition and develop that
and make it stronger and more use to
getting that load passed through it
although it's not yet part of the
feasibility project the uk space agency
has been supporting the development of
the hi-fi m
later this year it'll be tested in
microgravity on a parabolic flight where
lee will become the first disabled
person to jump in zero gravity
we in society
tend to define someone by their
disability i thought i had to redefine
who i was within the parameters of
disability and i was wrong to do that
and in no other walk of life is someone
defined by something they're not good at
or something they can't do but if you
have a disability
then that can tend to define who you are
certainly from other people's point of
view
you know if you look at the definition
of disability by the world health
organization
where we've really moved globally is a
understanding that disability is a
combination of both an individual's
impairment
but then also how that interacts with
the environment and so you can have a
specific impairment take the amputee for
example but if that individual is then
working and living within an environment
that is fully accessible
then the disability so to speak really
melts away right and so
disability is really defined by our
environment and um
you know that's why all this work around
the para astronauts and thinking about
adapting space is really so innovative
and exciting because i think we have a
opportunity to really totally redefine
what is a
so to speak normal body and what needs
to be adapted
if the feasibility project is successful
the european space agency will be
looking to include para astronauts in
future missions including a trip to the
international space station by 2025
but beyond making space more accessible
the esa is also hoping a diverse crew
will give them an even greater chance of
success in future missions
[Music]
we know that diverse teams are better
teams we know that people that don't all
have the same life experience and don't
have all think in the same way come from
different countries work better together
it's the fantastic thing about working
the european space agency we're 22
different countries working together
and those different cultural backgrounds
and ways of thinking make us uh strong
and the same is true if you've got a
crew trying to go to mars the first time
you want a mix of people
different genders different backgrounds
different countries to make a stronger
team
the space industry is known for its
innovation
and the research and findings from the
feasibility program might not only
produce the first para astronaut but
also have an impact on how disability
and adaptation are treated back here on
earth
a lot of the adaptive technology that we
use here in the us
you know the speed of research and
development the speed of innovation
sometimes can be a little bit stagnant
and so i think that reframing that and
thinking about well how do you
best empower people with disabilities in
a space environment
how do you best empower people to be
astronauts has the ability to translate
to really push us a lot more quickly in
our innovation here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you